no one said working out is easy
sometimes you need that extra push just
to get a few more reps in but these
athletes simply won't stop even when
life throws them the toughest curveballs
for most of my life I was told that I
was never gonna be able to throw a curve
ball let alone pitch because of my
condition looking back on it I just want
to prove people wrong I just go up there
I grab the ball and I think to myself I
run this game
[Music]
growing up my mom my dad they wanted me
and my brother to play sports find
something that we love I got a lot of
stares and a lot of questions but for me
I was just like yeah I was born with it
like I don't know any other way this is
me Dylan has Proteus syndrome once the
baby is born their body parts never stop
growing and the first five years of his
life he had six surgeries but Dylan's
been able to deal with those and adapt
in my case it was my fingers and my toes
I can't really move these three fingers
and then these two I had issues that
most people take for granted like
buttoning up a shirt the sleeve ones
those are the worst he thinks that if
you can do it he should be able to do it
and he figures out how to do it
baseball has always been my favorite
sport but I've had some obstacles cuz
I've had to figure out how to catch cuz
I can't squeeze my glove and it's the
same thing with my curveball
most people have both fingers on it but
I just used one and I learned a new grip
the way the ball comes off of his middle
finger and ring finger he just gets a
lot more spin than normal people do it
turns out because of my condition I can
throw a curveball that few other
pitchers can even though I wasn't the
fastest pitcher and I didn't have the
greatest body for pitching I always knew
that I could pitch because I was
accurate and I could hit my spots when
Dylan came here as a freshman he was
never a guy that we thought was gonna
contribute as much as he did and almost
by accident he got his opportunity we
were playing our rival school in the
second game of the year and our pitcher
was struggling Dylan was the only
pitcher on the bench and he
through three scoreless innings and then
we kind of knew at that point that we
had something after that my er a was the
second best on the team the highlight of
the year for me was when I came two outs
shy of flowing and no hitter a lot of
people were surprised but I knew that I
could do it and it just showed everyone
that I'm a good pitcher my family was
always loving and said just being you
everything will work out I'm not sick
when I run like I'm really I'm just so
normal
you wouldn't think someone who goes
unconscious like 14 times a day runs
like you just wouldn't put it that way
[Music]
my name is Katie cook I'm 20 years old I
live in Dublin Ireland and I love
running always dying there's four two
types of epilepsy when - nine years old
a one of which which is frontal lobe
epilepsy so at the moment I have 14
seizures in the 24 hour period they used
to be 1617 so we're coming down slightly
which is whoo
okay fine I was getting really bad
dizziness from my medicine
it's went into the hospital and they
loaded me which is a term for epileptics
when you're going on like a new medicine
and I didn't wake up until six days
later I was in mobile for the goats up
two years I moved from being in a
wheelchair to being in the same her
frame when I gradually started getting
back into running it kinda gave me this
newfound energy I've done a why I put on
my running boots and started running I
feel like it's so cliched but you kind
of feel like on top of the world that
you could do anything like I don't feel
sick anymore
until I have a seizure of I don't like
Damas you know it's amazing feeling like
all the endorphins like pulsing here
your body it's great like I like it's
honestly like amazing I trade alone for
most my runs like during the week
however I do have a pal for my races
like official races which is dr. Colin
dotty so I have two rolls so first of
all I'm her doctor
the other role I play which is to be her
partner in running and my job is to make
sure that when katie has a seizure if
she's running that nobody carts her off
the course nope seizure
so before I knew Katie she would run
races and if they were in public people
would you know quite reasonably insists
that she be carried off the course which
to her displeasure so my job is to say
no you know that I am her doctor and
that she's fine that she'll recover and
then she gets up and she runs I don't
let anything really get in the way of
living life at all
I just don't think it's the way to go I
suppose yeah I don't I don't let that
burlap sea get in the way at all
football is the most popular sport in
Sierra Leone and in the city of Freetown
there is one very special team meet the
Flying Stars my name nawa mela Pia had a
play for some offline stir and beachy
football club Mohammed grew up playing
football but when he was only 10 years
old he stepped on a landmine and had to
have his right leg amputated and
unfortunately Muhammad isn't alone the
saloon flanks the amputee football team
now war affected amplitude bladder so so
did every member of the Flying Stars has
lost limbs as a result of the violence
that occurred during the civil war in
Sierra Leone but the players don't let
their injuries stop them from getting
into the game go to give them questions
ready jump really rough then they blew
one foot one leg my name na by Charlie I
mean
coach for the Flying Star and PT
football club presently in a free Toya
taxi Plaza where Valley over the Train
Fulton 12 ish well golly way to okay
country welcome they walk in put gas on
trend get Willie woody do less shots
shots to Ornish desert and shorty clunky
penalty shootout I will select 70
normally out the ability to not only is
it a competitive sport it is helping
them cope with their injuries and
overcome the stigma that's associated
with the disabled discrimination honest
- control film self we need for do some
civic [ __ ] problem
in what better way than football
elec football especially and achievable
19 life and I'm a Canadian ostrich for
would be nonlinear of college that's not
only men be completely out there when
I'm out there riding my bike and I have
this pump on it's almost like it's not
even there
I just feel the freedom of being out
there and feeling the speed and
adrenaline I just hang out there riding
her bike so might say I'm like Dora the
Explorer
cuz I'm always wearing this backpack but
this backpack keeps me alive my name is
Hannah Jordan I'm from Tulsa Oklahoma
and fifteen years old and I'm a
competitive cyclist my long-term goals
are to become pro and be in the Olympics
in 2020 for Tokyo and bring back the
Tour de France for women I have an
unknown rare metabolic disease from when
I was very little I was in and out of
the hospital and very sick all the time
and when I was nine they gave me only a
couple months to live it's like I sort
of skipped childhood my mom took me all
over the country so some specialists and
they found a solution and they gave me a
thing called a g-tube that pumps sugar
into my stomach it basically keeps my
blood sugar at a normal rate I've always
wanted to do competitive stuff but for
most of my life I couldn't play sports
because of my condition when I got on
the bike it was almost like my problems
weren't there it's just been like a
whole new world open up to me
this one right here is really special
this was her first one and it's a silver
medal but she'd actually only been
riding a bike two months
and then shortly after that she did this
one she did 101 miles in 5 hours and 18
minutes which is very very fast and
that's kind of when we realized that she
probably was going to be pretty good at
this this weekend I will be competing in
Tulsa tuff a three-day race each day
thousand racers compete from six
different countries around the world
these women are usually 20 and above
[Music]
my mom and my dad they're my biggest
supporters they take me to all the races
and help me make it in cycling my mom
she helps me get everything ready and my
dad at the 200 meter mark he starts
yelling it's like a mental marker like
when I starting to sprint what makes me
different from other cyclists is the
ability to tap in that willpower and
determination I like to tell people it's
sort of coded in my DNA to be a fighter
anyone that's been in the hospital for a
long time where's gone through some
struggles or pain or suffering they just
know how to dig deep and tap in and to
be resilient and even if you lose some
days and win some others you have to
keep getting back up each and every
single time to go out there and ride
your bike
[Music]
you